comme chaque matin alphonse grutten fait
le tour des rayons du supermarché où il
travaille alors que d'autres sont
chargés de les remplir lui retient des
produits de la vente avec des règles
bien précises
donc on regarde les dates qui ne sont
plus vendable donc nous nous retirons de
la vente nous laisse canon comme ça nous
avons une trace de ce que nous donnons
aux associations comme avons terminé le
rayon nous allons mettre ça au frais
pour respecter la chaîne de froid et
vers 9h 9h15 l'association bière et puis
viennent le chercher dans un véhicule
réfrigéré mètres ce qui doit y être on
se retrouve dans un frigo à l'arrière
une pratique ancienne non ce supermarché
mais désormais obligatoire dans la
commune depuis 2012 la mairie a en effet
imposé le don des invendus alimentaire
aux associations le maire se rappelle
toutefois de débuts difficiles il y à de
la résistance au changement changement
d'habitudes et notamment au niveau de la
grande distribution au fait qu'on leur
ait pose la redistribution de ses
invendus
on s'est dit localement nous pouvons
également agir et c'est comme ça qu'on
essaie de trouver une formule pour
pousser la grande distribution à
redistribuer leurs invendus recours
déposé par des enseignes mauvaise
volonté flagrante
il aura fallu une première amende de
5000 euros infligée à un magasin pour
que tous s'engagent pour les enseignes
de la ville comme pour les associations
habilitées à collecter la mécanique est
désormais rodée et de nouveaux outils
pourrait voir le jour pour optimiser
cette pratique
carrefour en belgique ne demanderait pas
plus que chaque magasin le fasse que
chaque association puisse en profiter et
qu'on passe par un logiciel au niveau
national où chaque association soit
contrôlé par la sq a bien évidemment par
le gouvernement et que les invendus que
nous mettons à disposition des
associations soient également cherché et
donc redistribuer à ceux qui ont en
besoin
montagneux
l'exemple d'herstal a depuis essaimé des
dizaines de communes du pays ont repris
ce qui d et la région bruxelloise comme
celle de wallonie ont engagé un
processus législatif ou généraliser
cette obligation
une aide précieuse pour les associations
caritatives chargé de redistribuer comme
ici à herstal où près de 200 familles
dépendent de cette association
il ya les annales à ayant tout regard
neuf et ceux qui à voilà comme les
brocolis sont bons on peut les
distribuer demain nous avons 4 5 5
magasins donc on fait une tournée et
nous donne les a vendues on n'aurait pas
eu assé rien qu'avec le carrefour avec
le nombre de personnes qui augmente plus
la conjoncture ah ben c'est une bonne
chose que la loi soit quand même sorti
parce que bon on a de la plus belle
marchandise et plus soit en quantité
pour donner aux personnes afin
d'accompagner cette obligation
les autorités sanitaires ont modifié les
règles de contrôle pour la grande
distribution comme pour les associations
allégeant notamment la traçabilité les
barrières ont été revus pour les banques
alimentaires surtout au niveau de la
traçabilité pour que cette lourdeur
administrative qui est clairement
considéré comme une barrière pour les
entreprises
à juste titre pour des associations
caritatives on ne peut pas passer les
trois quarts de sa journée à remplir des
papiers et bien l'afsca l' agence en a
tenu compte et a permis par cet arrêté
ministériel et cet assouplissement
spécifique pour les banques alimentaires
a permis la de faire perdurer l'activité
de l'association caritative
l'exemple d'air ce talent donne
désormais des idées à d'autres
le parlement européen a voté en juillet
dernier un amendement demandant la
commission européenne d'agir sur ce
sujet une urgence quand on sait que 20
millions d'européens dépendent de l'aide
alimentaire pour survivre